we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p you can call
any time of day here is a really
interesting question about the phrase i
don't know as in i don't know the answer
to that take a listen david gets through
then cool so i just wanted to see what
your thoughts were about this sort of
concept I feel as though many political
figures as well as just people in
general are sort of scared to say things
like I don't know or I need to look more
into that that sort of thing and the
landscape of like seemingly endless
political facts personally I would love
the sort of authenticity but I think
many people are scared of like a Gary
Johnson Aleppo kind of situation so
anyway let me know your thoughts were
about that yeah I've been talking about
this for a while I would much rather
hear from people I don't know enough
about that yet to have an informed
opinion and I I simply I'm not in a
position to take a strong position in
one way or the other on that right now
the problem is that while if you don't
know something you you should you should
be comfortable saying that you are under
informed about that you also might be in
a position where you should know about
that thing right so in other words when
Herman Cain was running in 2008 or 2012
I think it was and on so many issues he
said I don't know but I'm gonna put in a
team and they're gonna figure it all out
at a certain point you've got to know
something about important issues if you
are trying to say I should be elected to
do something or I should be the CEO or
whatever the case may be there's no
problem in principle with recognizing
where you lack information or you lack
knowledge and simply saying that you are
going to get more informed as a societal
principle that is a good thing that
doesn't mean that being uninformed in
every situation is innocent or not
something that we should be concerned
about so I think that's the difference
when gary johnson said what's aleppo the
issue was not necessarily that he didn't
have a fully fledged out policy on a lap
and troop movements and foreign policy
issues around that that's one thing he
seemed to have no idea what Aleppo is
the fact that Aleppo is a seer is a city
right so that that was the problem and
while as a society we should encourage
recognizing where we have information
shortfalls understanding where we lack a
nuanced nuanced enough understanding of
an issue to take a position there are
times where if you don't know you
probably just shouldn't be in the
position you're arguing you should be in
and it's important to keep those two
things separate we've got a fantastic
bonus show for you today we will talk
about Bernie Madoff asking for
compassionate release we will talk about
paid dad leave in addition to mom leave
in Finland and very bad news for Macy's
the retail chain all of those stories
and more on today's bonus show